bon les Canadiens ont fait preuve
d'habilité hier devant des 10 000 femmes
à peu près là mais là on passe aux
choses sérieuses demain c'est
mais je peux vous dire par candidats que
ça dans la vie vous aussi vous avez fait
preuve d'habileté vous saviez que le
premier février 1983 c'était votre
premier jour de service continu à
Radio-Canada et c'est l'heure maintenant
dans la prendre un petit peu plus sur
vous et de vous célébrer célébrer vos 40
ans avec toute l'équipe qui va arriver
qui va se joindre à nous éventuellement
40 ans c'est pas c'est pas banal
Marc-André c'est la direction qui nous a
fermé tout ça et on pensait que c'était
une bonne idée de vous rendre hommage ce
matin parce que Marc-André Masson et
dans vos écrans tous les matins depuis
très longtemps évidemment et on va
regarder quelques extraits si vous
voulez de votre carrière voilà
à Toronto bonjour bienvenue à direct
quantité de poissons
Marc-André Masson comment on fait
l'émission habituellement on va aller au
mur vers
qui vous êtes
carrière c'est impressionnant mais ce
qui lit d'autant plus à mon sens c'est
la façon marc-andrée dont vous écrivez
votre prénom on remarque tout de suite
l'absence de trait d'union donc c'est
une façon assez unique d'écrire
Marc-André non on comprend bien mais ce
qui est unique aussi c'est l'homme
l'animateur que vous êtes alors vous
savez au mur on aime les faits alors on
va replonger dans votre carrière de 40
ans qui s'est amorcé le 20 janvier 1983
vous avez été on le sait toratour
animateur journaliste en fait
journaliste animateur vous avez
travaillé partout au pays à l'époque
j'avais moins 10 ans le 20 janvier 1983
j'étais même pas un projet
à ce moment et vous avez animé vous avez
été à la base de l'Ouest en direct à
Winnipeg gantre 1992 et 2007 et à
l'automne 1995 en lien avec le lancement
de RDI vous avez dit ceci à prendre en
direct les nouvelles en même temps que
les téléspectateurs procurent beaucoup
de plaisir c'est enivrant c'est excitant
c'est inquiétant c'est un peu tout ça
c'est aussi peut-être parce que je
vieillis alors je suis Samy mur
finalement et c'est vraiment ce qui
décrit le mieux votre travail vous êtes
à RDI matin devenu d'abord l'info depuis
12 ans on a des statistiques assez
impressionnantes pour vous ce matin plus
de 220 émissions par année pour un total
de 2470 missions ensuite
10.560 heures en ont et en direct tous
les ans en fait pas tous les tous les
ans oui
7900 entrevues menée depuis donc ces
douze années parce qu'on compte quand
même trois entrevues tous les matins et
plus de 5000 heures de sommeil volées
l'équivalent de 220 jours mais laisse
l'autre côté pour le moment les faits
les données et on a un message bien
senti qui vous est destiné
merci et félicitations pour toutes ces
belles années d'engagement à nous livrer
les nouvelles avec ton approche humaine
et à la portée de tous toi
pour 40 ans de service on est très fier
de toi un beau et bonjour du Royaume-Uni
et je voulais te féliciter
pour papa l'exemple depuis qu'on est
tout petit qu'il est important de
travailler fort en équipe et surtout des
persévérance pour moi une grande source
d'inspiration pour ma vie et pour mes
choix de carrière ça a été quand tu
m'amenais tout psy au bureau à Winnipeg
pour rencontrer tes collègues ou un peu
le studio
ce que c'est
parler des faits avec confiance un calme
à travers les bons moments les mauvais
moments un mot ta carrière pour moi
c'est la résilience tu m'as inspiré et
affronter tous les obstacles qu'on peut
faire face avec
de l'espoir et de la persévérance donc
je t'en remercie un gros salut
ça c'est la famille Marc-André mais là
en famille c'est nous ici je sais que
vous avez fait beaucoup de choses dans
votre carrière vous êtes allé au jeu
olympiques les couvrir souvent on a
quelques extraits de vous notamment
découvre ces jeux qu'on peut voir
maintenant allez maman exceptionnels
par exemple
et il y a aussi l'autre famille qui est
à l'étranger parfois Marc-André on a un
message tout spécial de Tamara alterisco
pour vous
Marc-André Masson 40 ans de carrière ça
se peut pas te l'air trop jeune
tolpette l'énergie de la passion et
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
moi j'adore travailler avec toi peu
importe où je suis dans le monde je suis
en Arménie on aura sûrement l'occasion
de se parler
c'est toujours enrichissant de ce savoir
écouter tu laisses la place à tes
invités
c'est un rendez-vous est manquable pour
moi quand je pars à l'étranger de
partager ce que je vis sur le terrain
donc bravo pour 40 ans de carrière
de pas être cynique de continuer ce que
tu fais avec passion moi je serai
toujours là pour toi même si tout le
matin je t'embrasse très fort bonne
chance pour le reste
et macadré moi aussi je serai là tôt le
matin avec vous encore parce que vous
êtes une source d'inspiration merci pour
tout et maintenant à Jules Jasmine nous
on se connaît Marc-André ça fait 12 ans
je sais que nous on le sait les gens
sans doute à la maison et vous êtes
d'une gentillesse infinie vous avez un
réconfort dans la voie une écoute aussi
peut-être parce que trois femmes à la
maison
et honnêtement il est fait avec tout le
monde les femmes les enfants les animaux
même les extraterrestres quand ils vont
venir sur cette planète marquanté
à la maison on va vous accueillir je
pense je l'ai vu fâcher quoi deux fois
en 12 ans ça devrait pas près de minutes
et demi
et la grande question est-ce que
Marc-André Masson est un robot pourquoi
il ne se plaint jamais d'être fatigué
contrairement à Martine et moi
il s'élève le plus tôt il ne s'est
jamais plaint de cette fatigue là alors
je me suis demandé c'est quoi son grand
secret c'est mon fils de 5 ans qui l'a
découvert il sait pourquoi vous n'êtes
jamais fatigué on va l'écouter lui
d'accord
[Rires]
salut ma calorie qui a un café devant
une petite rétrospective toujours bien
vêtue ça fait partie de son
professionnalisme et là on va s'amuser
un peu évidemment avec les looks au fil
du temps vous allez quand même remarquer
que la chevelure fait partie de
l'élément alors au moment où il a
l’impère assez belge et le cheveu par
dessus les oreilles et aussi ça pas
nécessairement changé il y a toujours
l'espèce de pénur légèrement un peu
Playmobil mais qui ne bouge pas beaucoup
dépendamment des époques on vous en
tiendra pour hier évidemment parce que
vous avez travaillé dans les années 80
90 et même maintenant les années 2000 et
qui le cru on est rendu en 2020
maintenant
vous m'avez complètement surpris moi
j'attendais rien de ça
les derniers commentaires comme vieille
complice vieux couple et Louise m'en
voudra pas elle va comprendre ça va
au-delà d'ailleurs de l'émission du
matin vous étiez à l'ouest en direct
j'étais à l'Ontario en direct oui oui on
est les vieux de la vieille Marc-André
je veux pas c'est ça on va pas se faire
de pelle d'ailleurs il m'a souvent
prénommé Maxime alors Maxime bonjour à
la maison et on va je voulais bien se
rappeler un moment 2019 ça fait quand
même un petit bail
donc ils sont de retour de vacances
vous avez pas besoin de vider votre sac
à l'entrée il y a pas de détecteur de
métal ici ça va aller
la sécurité
de la tempête tropicale en sucette
attentivement
[Rires]
maintenant il y a des gens qui sont
derrière la caméra qui avait un petit
mot à vous dire
[Musique]
toujours de bons conseils à l'écoute
drôle hyper professionnel c'est un
plaisir chaque jour de se lever aux
petites heures pour le travail je
t'embrasse toi 10 pas 20 pas 30 mais 40
ans de mariage la Radio-Canada bravo
Marc-André ce sont vos noces d'émeraude
pierre de la sagesse qualité d'une
personne avec beaucoup de patience
félicitations Mac André
présentement on est en régie dans
derrière la caméra mais on voulait quand
même prendre quelques secondes pour
souligner ton 40 ans de service à
Radio-Canada et on voulait te dire
tout ça est très mérité
vous avez été des champions à tout faire
ça sans que je me rends compte oui dans
mon dos parce que je suis tendance à
être un peu curieux puis signifie
toujours un peu tôt mais vous avez été
fort habile trouver tout ça merci
beaucoup cher ami parce que c'est
effectivement c'est pas je travaille pas
moi je viens m'amuser ici avec vous tout
en faisant notre travail hein
est-ce qu'on a vraiment du plaisir à
penser oui c'est à cause de vous
m'attarder exactement
[Applaudissements]